what is going on there reject nation
greg here today to talk about doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
specifically i wanted to jump in on the
conversation about mutants a lot of
people are speculating that mutants will
finally be introduced through this movie
and i have a theory that may sound a
little far-fetched at first but if you
stick with me on this journey you'll see
where i'm coming from
hopefully so if you guys could go ahead
and hit that like button i very much
appreciate it and let's just dive right
into this so before even the fox merger
even happened the big question has been
when will mutants come into the mcu
there's been a lot of popular theories
floating about one theory being thanos's
staff created mutations in human genes
another popular theory is that the
eternals already set up mutants because
in the comics the genetic experiments
that the celestials performed created
the x gene and another popular theory i
was hearing going about was that the
dreaming celestial at the end of the
movie the energy emitted from that
celestial kick-started the mutant gene
now after eternals we still haven't
heard anything about mutants what has
been like the common theory for doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
mutants will be introduced via the
multiverse and then through a series of
cataclysmic events it will result in
presumably wanda maximoff aka the
scarlet witch essentially rewriting
parts of the mcu timeline in which
mutants do exist presumably the fox
x-men universe opening the door for
essentially a multiversal rewrite or
reset allowing the birth of mutants to
exist within the main universe so in
short it would be a reversal from what
happens in the house of m comics you
might have heard this comic brought up a
lot in that comic scarlet witch is the
main threat and in the end of the story
she blames mutants for the world's
problems using her reality bending
abilities she declares the famous words
no more mutants so the common theory is
that this movie would end essentially in
a reversal of that with like a let there
be mutants which sounds cool that sounds
fine but my theory is this what if the
mcu timeline we've been watching for the
last 13 years
no more mutants has already happened
like i said i know this sounds like a
bit of a reach however i think this
would answer some questions we've had
about the mcu questions specifically
regarding the events of wanda vision i
think it would better help reintroduce
x-men and mutants into the marvel
cinematic universe and with this phase
after wanda vision loki the demon the
trailer for moon night this is called
multiverse of madness this is the
mind-bending phase of the mcu what more
of a mind-bender would it be than to
reveal to us that mutants were already
there and that the actions of the
scarlet witch erasing the existence of
mutants already happened dive into this
with me spider-man no way home that
showed us it's possible to erase people
from the world's memory including doctor
strange via forgetting who peter parker
was spoilers for spider-man no way what
if this movie takes it the next step
further since wanda vision was announced
everyone has been looking to the house
of m comic book that's like the go-to
source material to better understand and
perhaps predict what might happen in the
marvel cinematic universe now that's an
important comic but the comic that i'd
recommend looking into is actually one
of the follow-ups the house of m x-men
endangered species in that comic after
the existence of mutants has already
been reduced from millions to only
hundreds around the world hank mccoy aka
beast sets out on a journey to find a
way to reverse the spell wanda cast and
along this journey he eventually meets
up with dr strange who tells him exactly
this what she did completely change
reality that it's nearly impossible to
see where reality ends and her
alteration of it begins she cast her
spell over billions of souls over worlds
and dimensions reality has been consumed
by her spell the magic is woven through
everything welded to all there is so in
the source material itself doctor
strange declares her spell affected
worlds and dimensions i.e the multiverse
i tried rhyming that didn't quite work
so the main rumor ever since this movie
was announced at comic-con is that wanda
maximoff will be the main villain of
this movie and another rumor that's been
circulating is that the illuminati might
be featured in this movie and they would
essentially act as protectors of the
multiverse who are here to stop
multiversal threats with this being a
doctor strange movie with the few
appearances that we got of scarlet witch
in a movie about traveling the
multiverse why would wanda maximoff be
considered the ultimate threat to the
multiverse is it because the illuminati
believe in witchcraft lore i don't think
so maybe this is the real reason why
agatha harkness who once possessed the
darkhold which grants access to the
multiverse told wanda you're supposed to
be a myth so am i saying that we're in
some repeated time loop where the wanda
we've been with the whole time has
already done this no i'm not saying that
loki has already introduced us to
variants so as we saw in the setup of
that show a variant of our protagonist
was considered a multiversal threat so
what if in another universe the events
of wanda maximoff being brought to the
breaking point of mutants already played
out and she declared no more mutants
affecting all the timelines especially
the one that we've been watching for the
last 13 years spider-man no way home
showed us that just because variants
exist does not mean they are running on
exactly the same timeline case in point
toby maguire's peter parker for sure his
character is a lot older than tom
holland's peter parker this could be a
similar thing with wanda maximoff just
in another universe with the powers the
scarlet witch possesses her ability to
warp reality combine that with the
ending events of loki where all that
timelines were starting to intersect and
began crossing practices went into chaos
that could explain why some things in
wanda vision registered to her as
familiarity which were brand new to us
even to her for example the one division
series would lead us to believe that
tommy and billy were just something she
imagined up that she gave birth to and
in like a week went from babies into
these preteens and for some reason
stopped growing at that specific age yet
when she's using the dark hole at the
end of wanda vision accessing the
multiverse she hears tommy and billy
crying out for her essentially the
show's way of telling us these children
are not purely imagination but in fact
real children her mind could be
connected to a variant of herself that
already declared no more mutants in
order to have a rewritten life so she
could have the family she wanted a line
that stood out to us in that show was
when she tells her children thanks for
choosing me to be your mom isn't it just
a little bit odd that if she does
traverse the multiverse find tommy and
billy that they are indeed exactly like
how she
imagined in our universe and even take
evan peters showing up in wanda vision
as frustrating as it was to learn that
he's just some guy called ralph boner
believe me i didn't like that either but
i thought about it some more when he
shows up at their doorstep she instantly
recognizes him despite the fact that he
looks and behaves totally different than
aaron taylor johnson she recognizes he
is indeed pietro we come to find out
it's not but agatha needed someone that
upon wanda seeing would instantly
recognize as her brother even though
wanda at one point questions why do you
look different she still recognizes him
as her sibling maybe perhaps she's
connected to a variant version of
herself where her brother looks like
evan peters maybe the fox universe
here's where i'm coming from to
introduce mutants into the mcu it's a
major change-up and would drastically
affect the timeline if they wanted to
adhere to the source material if it was
like ah mutants now exist now we gotta
like kind of do some of the prejudice
allegories that that comic draws so like
even though the mcu does deviate from
source material the mutants have been
around since practically like the
beginning of time and they grew to be
more known to the world by the 20th
century and in the marvel cinematic
universe we've already had events like
avengers and games were countless heroes
many with superpowers super beings came
together to defeat a universe doom
threat a big part of bringing mutants to
the big screen like you just have to
have this if you're gonna bring mutants
is dealing with the hatred humans have
against mutants dealing with the racism
allegories now in the mcu after all
these super beings have done for us and
just how much they're celebrated i'm
just having a hard time wrapping my head
around the thought of humanity just
suddenly singling out mutants
specifically if they were to be
introduced as brand new beings into the
mcu timeline plain and simple you just
can't do mutants without the inclusion
of the the prejudices it presents so
maybe the way to handling it is
restoring the mutants into the mcu
causing everyone to remember their
animosity towards mutants before the
legendary words of i am iron man well i
just don't think it's that far fetch of
a plan any more so didn't like let's
just smash multiverses together and to
create mutants kevin feige the man of
many secrets unusually unveiled a while
ago the alternate post-credits scene for
iron man this isn't like something kind
of like out of the ordinary for the guy
to do and everything he says and does
presents is so intentional and in that
post-credits scene one thing that nick
fury says is this as if gamma accidents
radioactive bug bites and assorted
mutants weren't enough why would kevin
feige unveil their original plan to us
maybe because he was hinting that
mutants
were already there the original post
credit scene which was actually scripted
and filmed indicated that there are
mutants living amongst us and hiding
some believe that perhaps the best way
to introduce mutants would be they've
been in hiding and now feel comfortable
to come out but mutants come in the form
of millions not just a few who are
banned together like hiding like the
eternals it's not something like that
original post-credits scene would line
up with the idea that there are
currently only hundreds of mutants and
not millions of mutants just like house
of m anyway guys that's just my little
film theory for today and that's just a
theory a film theory but yeah guys what
do you think tell me how ridiculous it
sounds tell me if you think it sounds
plausible at all what's your theory of
how mutants will come to the mcu thank
you so much for joining me on this
journey catch you guys soon